[Music]
good evening I'd like to welcome
everybody to tonight's chess class it's
on open chess openings in particular the
Rory Lopez is white that's a third move
in the double King pawn opening where
white plays Bishop to b5 attacking the
knight on c6 this is considered the one
of the most promising lines of attack
for a white and it was world champion
Bobby Fischer's favorite chess opening
and he played several games with it
against Boris Spassky in the 1972 World
Championship Boris Spassky liked to play
a defense called the to the right low
PES called the Brier variation that's
what we're going to go through tonight
it's considered one of the most one of
the strongest defenses to the ruie Lopez
it black builds a very strong position
it's a defensive position and it's hard
for white to break through it's still
popular today as it was in Fishers time
the guy who designed the opening was a
Hungarian named Kela Brier in 1910 he
won the Hungarian championship he was a
very inventive individual and he was one
of the founders of the hyper modern
chess school starting around 1910 to
1925 the other one of the other major he
was a friend of Richard reti who he was
also famous for the hyper modern school
and aron nimzowitsch and savvy elet
arctic our anyway breyer was a brilliant
chess player but he had he suffered from
a serious heart problem and his heart
gave out he died at the age of 28 but
anyway his chess Fame lives
there are several other variations in
chess named after it but this is his
most famous contribution to chess
so we'll start going through the opening
this game that we're going to go through
there is a Russian named Dmitri Coco Rev
grandmaster rated 26 36 very high he's
playing one of the top ten Russian
players in the world Peter Swift ler his
ratings 27:45 they had a draw this was
played in the Russian championship the
69th Russian championship in the city
niversity Bursk October 20th 2016
just as a sideline that Russian City
happens to be the st. at one of the
scientific centers in Russia and it's
very popular chess owner as well all
right let's jump into the opening so the
first move is efore e5 Knight f3 knight
c6 Bishop to b5 this is the Rory Lopez
they all start out this way we're going
to look at this particular line where
black kicks the bishop right away with a
six this particular approach for black
was popularized by America's first world
champion Paul Morphy in 1858 before the
Civil War he was from New Orleans they
so this this part of the opening was
named after Paul Morphy it's called the
morphe defense now because the bishop is
considered to be a little better than a
knight even though they both are given
three points each in the valuation or
threat there were three pawns each white
doesn't want to give up the bishop for
the night so he retreats it now Blackman
black is behind in development white has
two pieces out black only has
so black develops his night notice that
he follows the opening principle of
every move is a different piece or
senator pong or upon the a6 pawn didn't
lose time because the bishop had to
retreat so he didn't lose time with that
move
now the knight comes out to f6 it
attacks the pawn on e4 which is not
defended so you want to develop your
pieces and make attacking moves whenever
you can and black is following that
principle white castles he doesn't
bother to defend the King pawn because
you can see if Knight takes the King
pawn the rook can come over to be one
attacking the knight and if the knight
retreats then the knight on f3 can take
the pawn on e5 opening up the rook
toward the black King so white didn't
have to defend the King pawn he just
Castle because the rook over here so
strong of course black doesn't take the
pawn the main line black plays the
bishop in front of the King now that's
there for defensive purposes see how it
blocks it when the RIC goes to e1 it'll
block the rook toward the king and the
bishop on e7 protects the f6 knight in
case the white bishop goes to g5 to try
to pin the knight against the Queen so
Bishop to e7 anticipates that when
you're looking at chess openings it's
more important than memorizing the moves
the thing you want to try to understand
is why every move is made every move in
chess has a purpose so when you're
learning and opening or learning more
about an opening that you may already
know you want to ask yourself why did
the Grandmaster make this move and
there's always a good reason for
so we'll go through the reasons now if
you know the reasons for the move
eventually you can memorize the moves
and that works hand-in-hand but it's
more important to know why the move is
made than what the move is if you just
memorized the moves after 15 or 20 moves
you won't know what to do unless you
know why the moves are made okay so
anyway what once black plays the Bishop
to e7 now he threatens to win that pawn
by Knight takes e4 and if where it comes
back he can drop his Knight to c5 and
attack the bishop on a4 and if white
takes the pawn black just castles you
see he can castle and there's no that's
no check by the work on the e5 so white
protects the pawn with auric to e1 now
you might say why didn't white protect
the pawn with pawn to Queen 3 or d3 our
Knight to c3 the reason is those are
good playable moose but white wants more
out of the opening than equality white
wants to get to center pawns he wants to
get that pawn that's on d2 to d4 side by
side the pawn on e4 but he doesn't just
want to move it there right away cuz
black would take it then he doesn't get
the two Center pawns
so what White's going to do he's going
to play the pawn on c2 to c3 first then
play the pawn on d2 and if black takes
the pawn on d4 then he takes back with
upon and he has his two son of pawns and
he controls all the center squares with
his pawns
that's so white is playing for a win and
playing the most aggressive moves so
rook to e1 and that's why he doesn't
bring his Knight to c3 or the pawn to d3
he has bigger plans for his pawns now
that white black is threatening the win
well white well actually white is
awesome
threatening after work to e1 White's
threatening to win the ePHI pawn by
Bishop takes Knight the the pawn on g7
takes c6 the Knight takes pawn and if
Queen goes to d4 attacking the night the
night drops back to f3 attacks the Queen
and the Queen can't take the pawn on e4
because it's protected by the work on a
one
so anyway whites now threatening to win
the pawn on e5 after Bishop takes Knight
so black has to drive the bishop back
with b5 the fact that black can play b5
that's the reason he earlier played the
a6 move kicking the bishop to a4 cuz he
knew he might have to drive the bishop
back with b5 so the bishop retreats
now black strengthens his son or pawn he
has a strong defense leap aunt chain the
pawn on e5 d6 and c7 that's a black pawn
chain it's very strong
now remember white wants to get those to
pull do Center pawn so he plays c3 here
and he's getting ready to play d4 black
because d4 is going to come and then
white could trade center pawns black
needs to get his King out of the middle
of the board so he castles now white
would like to play pawn to Queen for
right now but white can't afford to do
pawn the Queen for cos black can play
the bishop on c8 to g4 pinning the night
and then once the Knights pin black
threatens pawn takes pawn on d4 C pawn
takes pawn black can do Bishop takes
Knight and if Queen takes bishop then
the knight can win the pawn on d4 if
working the Queen and the bishop winning
a pawn trading off White's Bishop that
black should win the game now white
could
in answer to the bishop the g40 takes on
f3 he wouldn't lose the pawn if he did
the G pawn takes on f3 but he would have
double pawns and he had would have
ruined his King side pawn structure so
before white plays pawn the Queen for he
has to prevent Bishop to g4 so he plays
h3 we're at the point where the Brier
very defense starts to the worry Lopes
and it's interesting to contrast the
Brier defense with another defense
called the chigorin defense named after
a famous Russian chess player now
chigorin in this position would play his
Knight to a5 and attack the bishop to
drive the bishop off that look that nice
line on b3 and drive the bishop back so
the bishop okay so the bishop would come
back and then she Goren would shove this
C pawn see how the the pawn is on c5
along with the e5 pawn they'll fight the
pawn that White's gonna put on d4 so
then white plays d4 and the game goes on
from here but we're not going to go into
this opening I just want to show you the
older opening called the chigorin
defense the thing to note notice that
the black knight is on the side of the
board where it's not that effective
White's pieces are all in the center of
the board where they're more effective
so the one drawback to the chigorin
variation is he's going to have to move
that Knight again back to the middle of
the board at some point the chigorin
defense is still good for equality if
you play it just right the Brier defense
is a refinement of this defense
so now we'll go back to the Breyers move
and this move was very surprising to the
chess players at the time when he came
up with it
he actually retreats the knight back to
its starting point Knight to b8 that
violates the chess principle of not
moving the same piece twice in the
opening and not only that not only did
he move it twice he put it back where it
started but he had good reason for that
when the knight was on c6 C it blocks
the pawn on c7 black eventually wants to
move the pawn on c7 to c5 to attack
White's enter pawn that's going to be on
d4 so the knight move clears the way for
the black pawn to advance there's
another reason and we'll get to it in a
second so white carries out his plan and
plays d4 you see that white has the two
Center pawns
efore and d4 that's the most aggressive
pawn structure in the opening for white
and it puts pressure on blacks position
in particular the e5 pawn it's attacked
by the knight and the pawn on d4 and
it's only defended by the pawn so black
has to hurry and defend it one more time
now briars maneuver is to redevelop the
Knight to d7 where it protects the pawn
but notice here the knight is in the
middle of the board not on the side like
in the Chi Goren the knight defends the
pawn on e5 and it also defends the
knight on f6 so it's strengthened blacks
defense in the middle of the board and
on the Kings side and that was his
refinement
of the chigorin okay now white got the
pawn senri once but he he needs to
develop his Knight and his bishop on c1
he hasn't moved those yet now the bishop
he doesn't move the bishop now cuz
there's really no great square for it
if the bishop were to go to e3 it would
block the work from protecting the pawn
on e4 and that would not be good and if
the bishop were to go to g5 attacking
the knight look the Knights defended by
the bishop Queen and queen knight the
bishop on g5 is not going to do anything
and on top of that black could gain a
temple but played h6 and forced the
knight the bishop to retreat so what the
right idea for white is to work with his
Queen Knight first and develop the
bishop later on when the situation is
better for it so white develops the
knight to d2 now in this in the Rory
Lopez in this variation this that Knight
is going to go to f1 and from f1 to g3
so it's a three movement
B 1 D 2 f1 g3 now once it gets to g3 it
protects the pawn on e4 and can go to
the square f5 and it doesn't block the
bishop on c1 if the night went here into
e3 it would block the bishop and that
would be bad it would end the night here
would block the rook from protecting the
pawn this is a typical maneuver on the
white side in the the Rory Lopez you'll
see it all the time okay now black knows
white wants to retreat that night on D 2
to F 1 and then go to g3 so black
develops he needs to
develop that Bishop on c8 he boosts it
to be seven notice how it's on and this
diagonal attacks the e4 pawn and the
knight on f6 he and if it's that pawns
defended twice attacked twice white
can't move to f1 right now so white
needs to protect that pawn one more time
before he can do his knight maneuver the
best way he can protect that pawn he
voluntarily retreats this Bishop on b3
to see to see how the bishop protects
the pawn now remembering the Chico
earned defense the knight came here and
forced the bishop here right but in the
brunt but then the knight was stuck on
the side of the board now in the Brier
he goes here and here and white had to
voluntarily retreat anyway so by he had
his Knights in a better spot and the
result the bishop retreated that's why I
say the briars a refinement of the
chigorin defense okay so anyway he's
protecting the pawn he's going to do his
Knight to f1 and night to g3 but I can't
stop that anymore so blacks going to
develop redeploy he's going to develop
his rook on f8 and drop his Bishop on e7
to f8 move the pawn to g6 and fee and
shoveled the Bishop to g7 so he moves
rook to e8 white does Knight to f1
Bishop drops back to f8 now black is
threatening pawn takes pawn pawn takes
pawn Knight takes pawn and he's got it
the pawns attack three times it's only
defended twice black's threatening to
win a pawn but it it that doesn't bother
white White's gonna move his knight to
g3
protects the pawn and every whites fine
but notice that white his Knights are
good his Bishop is undeveloped his pawn
structure is aggressive and better than
blacks blacks isn't bad but blacks is
defensive okay now the other thing to
notice about black is all his minor
pieces are developed the bishop the
knight and even the bishop on f8 he's
going to redeploy the bishop he plays g6
now see how the g6 pawn takes the f5
square so the knight can't move here and
the knight can't move there and then the
bishop can come up to g7 and work on
this diagonal so that's what black is
aiming for and I think the Fischer
Spassky game is a little different but
we're gonna continue with this so white
plays a4 now black plays c5 remember I
told you that was one of the points of
the night was to get out of the way the
pawn and notice how the c5 and e5 pawns
are fighting the pawn at d4 black has
his share of the center squares white
plays d5 gaining space White has a pawn
on the fifth it cramps black to the
black has these four rows white has a
little more space but black has very
strong pawn structure and he's got his
pieces nicely developed so the fact that
he has a little less space that isn't
really a big too big a problem for him
now black plays c4 he has this pawn
change so if pawn takes pawn takes rook
takes the Queen can take or the bishop
can take but he pushed the pawn here it
takes this square in this square away
from the bishop
it opens up this square for the night
from here the night centralized and can
affect these squares so that's why he
played see for white plays Bishop to g5
he this was finally time to develop the
bishop now black has to kick the bishop
with h6 right now if he does some other
move like say Queen here to break the
pin this Queen goes here and the Queen
and Bishop prevent h6
so the right move for black is to hit
the bishop before the Queen can go to d2
forces the bishop to retreat now black
drops his knight to that center square
white gains at mousses develops his
Queen the Queen and Bishop were
attacking the pawn on h6
so either black has to move the King up
or he in this case he chooses to advance
the H pawn 1 square now white messes up
black's pawn structure he takes the nice
Knights the D pawn takes back and black
has double pawns and white has a
protected pass pawn but this pawn is not
going anywhere for a long time it's
blocked by the bishop in the Queen this
is approximately an even position maybe
a little bit better for white black has
two bishops but with all the pawns on
the board they don't have a lot of open
lines to work on White has a double pawn
to work against but blacks pawn
structure is pretty strong and the two
bishops give him plenty of defensive
capability so the evaluation of this
position is approximately even where we
will soon be at the end of the opening
white plays Queen to e3
attacking the pawn on c5 remember black
wants to move his Bishop on f8 to g7 he
can't do that now because the pawn on c5
is attack so he protects the pawn with
Queen to c7 now the computer gives this
as a slight advantage for white but not
a winning advantage somewhat less than
half of a pawn advantage okay now
they're different moves for white in
this position in this particular case
white chooses to retreat the knight to
f1 now you might be puzzled as to why
the knight would retreat to f1 I know I
was when I saw it but when the Knights
here
it can't go to h5 these white pawns keep
the knight for moving in and the knight
blocks this pawn here when the he brings
the knight here he's planning to play g4
at a point in the future to attack this
pawn and try to open up a line against
the black king we'll see that unfold
rook plays his eye black plays his rook
from the e-file to the b8 square he
moves here what he's thinking about is
he puts it on this line toward this pawn
that's unprotected and he's
contemplating pawn takes pawn and maybe
this bishop drops back here to c8
opening up the rook line on this pawn
he's looking for a counter-attack now
the computer says that as an alternative
black could play bishop - geez
seven which we talked about and this is
still a little better for white rook to
b8 is also a little better for white
because there's a drawback to the rook
move see how the work protects this pawn
and the Queen that's attacked by the
night when the rook moves over here it's
all up to the Queen to protect this pawn
so the Queen is tied to protect the pawn
if he kept the rook there his King side
would be stronger and the Queen would be
free to move somewhere else so when
black played were to e to be eight it
was what you call double-edged had its
pluses and minuses okay
now we're on move twenty-two and white
makes a minor mistake according to the
computer white takes the knight on f1
and moves it to d2 it's not a mistake in
the sense that black can went a pawn or
something it's a mistake in the sense
that white missed a better move and the
better move for white is a little
surprising but it's Queen to g5 just see
how the Queen now is attacking the black
king side position and the knight on f6
which is temporarily undefended the best
move for black is just to put the bishop
there to protect the night
and here's another surprising move but
the computer says it's the best move the
Queen retreats to h4 there's a reason
for that
when the queen is here the knight can
retreat to h7 and attack the queen
enforce it to retreat anyway white
anticipates night back and prefers not
to so he drops the Queen back right now
so that night back doesn't win a temple
and with the Queen here white is
contemplating pawn here the Queen
protects the pawn and he's getting ready
to do pawn takes pawn or once the pawns
here this night will come up here and
the knight pawn and queen will tech this
pawn and if this pawn takes here this
pawn here and then the rook files open
the King can come up the rook can come
over and the Queen and work can come
into the King so that's what that's
what's good about Queen to h4 it's a
good move okay
and one possibility black neat says oh
maybe I shouldn't have moved my work I'm
going to move it back white plays is g4
move black brings the other work over to
the center the knight comes up the
bishop drops back and the King comes up
and this is a little better for white
white defends the pawn the rook is ready
to come over here and at some point
maybe rook here and the King can come
here here opening up the rook line and
then play pawn takes pawn anyway this is
according to the computer it's about a
half a pawn better for white than black
anyway after this move which is not as
aggressive remember Queen here has a
real threat and prepares another threat
g4 this doesn't threaten anything it
gives black time so now it's a
completely even position
black plays Bishop to g7 he drops his
Bishop Bishop comes to c8 remember I
told you that black wanted to drop the
bishop to open up the rook line
now black threatens pawn takes pawn
bishop where it takes pawn and then
Werth takes pawn here so white has to
protect the pawn now black drops his
knight to e8 the knight can come here
and block the pass pawn and from this
square the knight can attack this pawn
white plays his Bishop up to e to the
knight comes up to d6
Rick comes over here now White's
planning pawn takes pawn pawn takes pawn
rook takes work winning a rook black
needs to protect that work on a eight so
he moves his Bishop back okay now white
makes another minor mistake he plays
another passive move he retreats his
Bishop to f1 again allowing black to
equalize he had a better move he could
have played more aggressively the more
aggressive move the computer recommends
is to play g4 which is an exclamation
mark attacking and breaking up the
black's pawn chain on the Kings side the
best move for black is to take the pawn
white takes back then into the queen
the Queen went to c8 because she has to
protect this pawn because the White
Queen is attacking this pawn now the
Queen threatens Queen takes pawn check
and the Queen and the rook and the
bishop defend this rook
that's why Queen here's the right move
and Queen here wouldn't be as good
because it would leave this pawn
unprotected okay so to protect the pawn
white moves the knight to h4 opening up
the bishop on e to now protects the pawn
on g4 now the Queen moves to a black
square d8 and attacks the knight that's
not protected white throws the pawn up
to g5 to block the Queen on the knight
but also see how the pawn blocks this
pawn and attacks this square and this
square he would and then white would
like to bring this knight in or maybe
move his his king out of the way and
bring a rook back over black can get
equality here with a very fine move he
needs to break up White's pawn chains
the right move is f5 now f5 attacks this
pawn it also has possibilities of moving
here where it attacks the Queen and once
here it blocks the Queen from defending
the pawn so the threat would be Queen
takes pawn check and if pawn takes pawn
pawn takes back now white could do pawn
takes pawn and passant and white could
also do Knight takes pawn it's getting
very complicated
the computer says Queen the g3 is the
best move and then it suggests pawn
takes pawn Knight takes pawn on g6 so
now this is threatening to win this pawn
but notice when this pawn took this pawn
this pawn is now unprotected and the
bishop can take this pawn so there is
lots of possible exchanges going on and
it's going to Peter out to a draw black
Tate takes the the d5 pawn when you're
defending as black is defending it's
very important to take the center pawns
when you can now the bishop was here now
it's in the middle of board and it helps
to defend the King site it can move back
here also this he could give this pawn
up as a sacrifice pawn here and then the
bishop would operate down on this
diagonal white plays rook to d1 now if
he moves the knight he'll attack the
bishop so the pawn moves up it's a pawn
sacrifice it opens up that diagonal for
the bishop Queen takes now we get the
knight in attacking the Queen so black
one a temple Queen goes to h3 attacking
the knight but leaving the g5 pawn free
so black takes that queen g4 now we have
a trade of Queens going to g4 Bishop to
g4
the night was attacked it has to drop
back and attack the bishop because his
bishop is in trouble
black hit white has 97 check winning the
bishop King attacks the knight Knight
takes the bishop and the Black Knight
takes the bishop and it Peters out to a
draw an ending however so in this
position white made a passive move and
he should have played g4 which black
could still hold the balance as we just
went through but white played a passing
move giving black and easier way to
equality so black just redeployed is
rook to e8 white did pawn okay now
here's an interesting thing at this
point in the game remember black is
higher rated top 10 player in the world
white decides to play for a draw he
could white could have played for an
advantage White's position is a little
better the computer says he could have
played for a slight advantage with h4
which would allow the knight to go into
g5 at some point and it would block
blacks pawns not a winning advantage
against about a half a pawn advantage
but white decided to liquidate all the
rooks and get a draw an ending
so we fairly rapidly get to a draw so at
this point the game is completely even
beep so the bishop on a 8 can't go
anywhere so the bishop comes here then
it can come back here and work on this
diagonal so it's important for black to
bring the bishop back to the middle of
the board now white plays h4 that's a
minor mistake when the pawn was here it
kept a piece from getting on this square
now this diagonal is open and the black
bishop can come here and here the pawn
was better here
so h4 is a minor mistake the computer
says that g4 would have been more
aggressive but again it's just it's just
equality after pawn takes pawn takes
Bishop takes hitting the pawn and g5
with an even position anyway h4 now it's
a little better for black not winning
though black drops is bishop back King
comes up pawn to f6 the pawn on f6 does
block the bishop but it takes this
square away from the knight and queen so
it's a a good trade off white is going
to liquidate the bishops now remember
White's playing for a draw so he's
trying to trade off the pieces now black
plays King to h7 to protect the pawn on
g6 white makes a mistake a real mistake
here it's the subtle mistake
he plays knight here and we'll get into
why that's a mistake in a second now
what white should have played he should
have dropped his Queen back here
dropping the Queen back here where it
defends the back row and that would have
been better and he should get a draw he
did that but actually after moving the
knight here there's a great maneuver
that black could win the game but black
black actually misses the right move but
black starts out correctly he plays the
bishop to h6
see how the bishop is on the queen and
the knight on here and if the knight
here was here the night would they were
the Knights would protect each other and
the Queen would be back here there
wouldn't be a gain of a temple when the
bishop moves so that's why the Queen
back was better okay now if the Queen
drops here the bishop takes the knight
the Queen takes the pawn is left
unprotected Knight takes pawn attacking
the Queen that should win the ending so
white has to block the bishop line with
the pawn move f4 now there's a pin here
and pawn takes pawn pawn takes pawn and
that pawns pin the Queen is on this line
blocked by the knight but that should
give black a combinative idea the Queen
and Bishop after pawn takes pawn pawn
takes pawn and threatening Bishop takes
pawn so the knight moves somewhere
opening up the queen line this pawns
pinned white would be in trouble
black makes a mistake that makes the
game of draw he plays Queen to a7
contemplating attacking down the a file
on this pawn and that night
baby Queen here Queen here it looks like
a good move and it's not a bad move it's
not a mistake but it's not the best move
so the best move was to move the knight
back the knight protects this square and
now the threat is pawn takes pawn pawn
takes pawn Bishop takes pawn winning a
pawn in the game White has to protect
the pawn so he has to play Knight to g2
black does pawn takes pawn takes now the
winning move for black and this is what
the top 10 player in the world probably
missed when he was calculating he missed
that he could play Knight to e5 because
this pawn is pinned and the knight comes
to this nice square where it's anchored
by the pawn and attacks the Queen this
was or the knight can come down here and
attack this pawn which is undefended the
knight can come here and attack this
pawn and white can't defend this pawn
see there's no Queen move to defend the
pawn no knight move and once that pawns
down black can get a passed pawn with
these three pawns against this one pond
by pawn here this would win black might
play Queen to g3 and the winning move is
Knight to d3 and there's no defense to
the pawn on b2 so even the top 10
players in the world make mistakes
he played Queen to e7 the knight goes
there Queen goes back to e7 Knight back
here so they're repeating moves they're
probably in time trouble Queen to d7
Shaq King to h2 Queen d7 Knight
to eat f/4g that 4f five night eat f3 f2
e4 Knight to g5 Czech Bishop H takes
King to g7 Queen to c5 getting the pawn
back
III Queen back to the center with Czech
King to g8 Knight to f3 the knight from
here can stop the pawn by Knight takes
pawn so this is the right square and the
knight can come up here maybe and attack
that pawn it's protected here and the
Queen can drop back and wipe out this
pawn so White's anyway black plays pawn
up obviously threatening pawn here
winning the knight white counter-attacks
attacking that this Knight
so if pawn up Knight takes Queen takes
Queen takes Knight and then White has a
dangerous pass pawn here so black can't
push the pawn up black goes back to h7
and the players agree to a draw the
computer says in the end black had he
missed another good move here he should
have played his knight back here now he
probably didn't they were probably in
time trouble it was near the end of the
game so they didn't have time to think
everything through black probably no
doubt he saw that if he moved the knight
here this pawn is unprotected and Queen
takes pawn check when's the critical
pawn and it
like blacks King is in trouble but what
black didn't realize he can move the
Knight to g7 the night there the queen
is here it protects this pawn and it
blocks the Queen from coming here with
check and then it frees the Queen up so
he can shove the pawn and win the night
the best move for whites is not to take
the pawn check because of the Knight to
g7 but to block the past pawn now white
but I can get the advantage Bray
attacking with his Queen he's
threatening the f4 pawn and the d5 pawn
the Queen has to drop back now the
knight can come to c7 and attack the d5
pawn it advances and the knight can go
to e6 and the threat is on this pawn and
this pawn can't go anywhere and black
has an advantage here it may not be a
winning advantage it's nearly a pot it's
a considered pretty good advantage but
it may not be winning so it's an
interesting game and it goes through the
Brier defense now we don't have much
time left but let me run through the
first moves of the Fischer game this
goes back to 1972 Fischer played for
Spassky for the world championship and
we'll just run through the opening a
little bit you've got the notes there on
the paper
so again ray Lopes a6 and we get to this
position remember in this position he
played the pawns so the bishop couldn't
pin
night now the breyer maneuver is the
retreat of the night and then over to d7
okay so now in the game we just looked
at the move was here to attack this pawn
and we can make this pawn weaker Fischer
took a different approach against Boris
Spassky and played here
Spassky played Bishop to f8 now Spassky
Bishop to f8 he can still get equality
but the easiest way to get equality
Spassky missed the best move according
to the computer the best move is a5 now
when white place the pawn here he maybe
wanted to play here and do pawn takes
pawn by coming here blacks two pawns he
can liquidate the if this pawn comes
here he liquidates the pawns and gets an
even game so by being aggressive and
leaving the bishop on e7 he could have
liquidated White's Queen side pawns and
it would have been an even game and the
main line goes like this Bishop to b2
Knight comes up here fighting for the
square and this square preventing this
move and if this move well then they can
trade pawn takes they can trade some
pieces white plays a3 he needs to
protect this pawn then he can shove this
pawn up now black can do trade this pawn
and place c6 now he played c6 blocks the
bishop but this pond was undefended the
threat was Knight takes pawn black had
to defend the pawn and the best way was
to bring this pawn here and it also
takes this square away
and the computer says that this is an
even game anyway Boris Spassky played
Bishop to f8 he can still that's the
traditional maneuver by the way the a5
would have been a new idea white played
a four-night to b6 white played a
five-night went back the bishop came up
and here
Spassky played Queen to b8 this leads to
an even game he's planning to play this
pawn here and then the Queen will
protect this pawn and the Queen can
operate down this way another way a
black could have gotten equality here
would be simply to play rook to c8
leaving the Queen in the mill the board
where she helps defend the center and
play he can play c5 and trade off these
pawns and that would lead to an even
game ok just a couple more moves so this
is an even position that never stopped
Bobby Fischer though he played here now
he's lined his rook up on the black
Queen black plays c5 to trade off the
pawns
so you can see the pawns are coming off
quickly some nights now white gets to
attack the black Queen with his Bishop
so he gains the temple black has the
good move Queen to f4 he takes the
knight the queen takes now white takes
the B five pawns he's winning a pawn
pawn takes pawn he can do rook takes
pawn now black says you can win that
pawn pawn takes pawn Bishop takes pawn
it blocks and passed pawn and the
Knights pinned to the Queen so white
would be in some trouble
white wisely doesn't win the pawn yet he
moves the Queen over to break the pin
now Spassky plays Queen to c3 that's an
okay move but he missed the best move
the best move for Spassky would be to
liquidate the pawn rook takes pawn he
gains the temple attacking the rook so
the bishop went from an unprotected
square to a protected square text the
rook now it
let's see white's upon up but the pawn
is not very useful for a long time it's
an isolated pawn blocked by the bishop
and the rook that pawn is not much of a
disadvantage to be at that pawn down
black plays here Knight to f3 and c4 and
according to the computer this is an
even game notice that in compensation
for being the pawn down black has two
bishops
open lines he has a strong pawn and
passed pawn here is rooks on an open
file the computer says this is an even
why actually says it's slightly better
for white but black should be able to
hold the draw anyway that's about as far
as we'll go tonight so that's a couple
different ways to look at the briar
defense it's considered perhaps the
soundest one of the sound is strongest
ways for black to defend the Rory Lopez
thanks thanks for coming
[Music]